I'm going to pull up this story from Fox
News a lot of people were talking about
this the video of Greta tunberg getting
arrested sending Twitter into a frenzy
time for many of us to stand up and you
got this clip where she's being carried
away with a smile on her face and then I
don't know if we we yeah we do have it
here people are saying it's staged
because you can see her laughing and
smiling with with some guy as the cops
are just standing there with her and
then they eventually just walk away and
she's not being carried I don't think
it's staged I don't I the cops were
probably told okay get the protesters
out of here I think it was staged in so
far as almost all non-violent Civil
Disobedience has staged as in protesters
will call the police and say hey we're
going to go here we're going to protest
just so you know then the cops say okay
we're gonna come arrest you and say okay
and then you can press but here's the
real story the real story is that Greta
tunberg's friends attacked a bunch of
journalists look at this from Andy no at
the autonomous Zone in luzoreth Germany
militant leftist an anti-fun climate
extremists surrounded and attacked
journalists
he's a great tunberg's friends huh
there's something I think people need to
bring up because I'm not I'm not playing
these games we've talked about the
banality of evil if Greta tunberg is
going to be associating with these
people if she's going to be organizing
protests and inviting these people and
if she will not call this out then she
is complicit and she supports it I read
it I remember playing eco-terrorism in
Civilization too it was my first
exposure as a young man to eco-terrorism
and I was like oh these people are
protective Sif too you could create
eco-terrorist care or might have been
the expansion of Civ 2 it had been
expansion yeah and you could create a
character that was an eco-terrorist that
could go and I was like oh they're
defending the planet but they're called
terrorists these are good units I want
eco-terrorists on my in my Army because
they're valuable and I'm like wait a
minute this is all why do they call them
terrorists if they're protecting the
Earth but I think Greta is willing to
use violence or associate with people
using violence because she thinks it's
that drastic you see that flag that's
the flag of violent leftist leftist
violence yeah and I mean hey there are
times and places that people have been
destroying things to the point where you
have to use violence to stop them from
destroying it but I don't think the uh
the global ecosystem is in that state
right now I'm not I'm not going to put
I'm not gonna make a moral judgment on
um on the protests I am going to make a
fact statement Greta tunberg's group
violently attacked journalists
is it a is it confirmed that they're all
in the same group were they just all
their kind of disparately Desperately
what does that even mean like they were
all there of their own volition didn't
know each other but some people were
violent some other people there there's
one protesting
climate stuff
well let's let's watch the video what
game I'm not going to play
is that these these leftists have long
done this where they quote unquote
respect A diversity of tactics and then
they'll they they will all feign uh
ignorance and reject responsibility for
what they organize which is violent
attacks on journalists it happens all
the time and then you'll get an
organization and it'll be called like
you know save the planet
and then when antifa shows up and gets
violent they go oh well that was us yes
they are otherwise you'd have kick them
out otherwise when that when that one
crazy dude showed up in Portland started
doing the Nazi salute or whatever they
threw him out and then all the woke
media ran pictures claiming he was at
their event it's like yeah getting
kicked out they said get the F out they
won't kick these people out they want
them there to respect their diversity it
concerns me man Greenpeace they would go
you know sink sink boats and blow up oil
tankers I don't know no I don't think
Greenbush ever did that destroy their
Bridges they're pacifists I'm pretty are
you sure I'm pretty sure I've seen what
about terrorists what happened with
green Greenpeace sea shepherds are the
ones that actually don't fight
Greenpeace they had a uh the French
government bombed one of their boats or
something like they blew it up now I'm
not saying green beans are good dudes
you know they do not they they will get
like water guns and they'll climb onto
boats and they'll wave flags and do
better drops but I'm pretty sure
Greenpeace isn't going around bombing
anybody or anything like that sea
Shepherds at hacked at Sea vessels
attacked so these guys are known as yeah
there's like those are pirates yeah but
pirates for Earth for planet Earth well
there's like a whole city I did say butt
pirates but pirates for planet Earth
yeah well okay so I still didn't see the
the attack because I see a lot of social
media posts to come up being like man
attacks dude and thing and I'm like what
did he do he got up in his face and
yelled at him that's not attack well if
you saw there like threw it on the
smartphone that they were using to
record they hear they kicked him in this
video yeah kind of mild harassment stuff
you know that's one thing I give antifa
a little credit for is that they don't
go too overboard they just kind of
pepper spray and beat you up a little
bit they don't actually shoot you or
stab you yeah
you know what the one thing I can say is
if I was going to have any sympathy for
antifa it's because we all are sick and
tired of journalists because like
they're just liar like they they lie for
corporations they lie for advertisers
yeah and if it's not them it's their
bosses who do it so it's just like
I get why antifa's mad they hate
journalists because journalists lie all
the time yeah but I'm opposed to
violence so like if Greta tunberg wants
to go to some protest and associate with
this then I'm going to call it like I
see it that's that's her group I'm not
saying she she organized that group I'm
not saying I'm saying she's with them so
you think she has a responsibility to
speak out against us right now
absolutely like when that dude showed up
to in in Portland I forgot the guy's
name and he started yelling the n-word
they said get the out of here like dude
it's tough for especially on the right
because the media will lie anyway and
then they will protect the left right
now I assure you Media Matters is like
writing something up where they're like
Temple lies and claims gratitude versus
violent or something and and that's the
challenge but I'm I'm I'm I'm not going
to play any games if you are like hey
everybody meet me here and then a bunch
of violent lunatics attack journalists
and then you're like don't look at me I
mean put yourself in the reporter's
shoes right you're there to try to
report say you're coming from a good
place you're just trying to cover what's
going on here because the corporate
media is very sympathetic to What's
Happening Here Al Gore is promoting
Greta tunberg today right so you're
there covering what's going on and you
got some people coming up you don't know
who they are you don't know if they have
weapons start kicking you slapping your
camera throwing you down saying get out
of here assaulting you slapping you
punching you and and whenever you put
your hands on somebody again you
shouldn't do that I covered a lot of
different protests faced a lot of
different in insane situations I got
assaulted I got jumped a couple times I
got beat up a couple times but uh the
best thing that I saw was in Hong Kong
where of course people there were
protesting against the Chinese
government the Chinese government was
using fake press as a way to get photos
and videos of protesters and then arrest
them and ship them away forever what did
the Hong Kong protesters do they didn't
assault journalists they didn't beat
them up but they figured out ways to
kind of do their thing to of course have
their face covered but also use
umbrellas in a way that prevented any
kind of conflict or escalations when
they were changing into black blocks
since they were using Black Block
tactics they used it in a way to not
force or hurt anyone but but obfuscate
their identity because there was a real
threat for the Chinese government coming
in and disappearing people and they did
it in a way that we didn't need any of
this nonsense any of this kind of threat
or assault of of journalists which we
should always try to avoid and speak out
against let's not lose sight of the
irony of a flag standing for
anti-fascism beating up journalists for
covering their well I love that there's
a meme where it's like a leftist yelling
just because the Nazis call themselves
socialist doesn't mean they're
socialists and then holding the idea of
a flag and be like of course we're
anti-fashion so then it's in our name
yeah yeah don't dig your word for it
whether you said Hong Kong
um Rebellion what would you even call
that an uprising uh resistance well the
Chinese state was coming in and not
keeping their promise that they had with
the UK government that they were going
to transition Hong Kong to China in a
very slow way the Chinese government did
it in a very fast way and was of course
also destroying a lot of key
institutions in Hong Kong and a lot of
the larger uh apparatuses and
institutions that provided a lot of
people Liberty they were getting rid of
that people protested and then there was
a violent Crackdown on the protests and
um it was just insane covering that
situation because it was truly so much
different than covering a lot of the
western protests that I've seen in
Greece or in Paris or even inside of the
United States where a lot of the the
things were totally opposite I heard
that they were putting crazy chemicals
and like fire hoses with like blue ink
and pepper and they would spray it and
stick on your skin yeah sticks on your
stick for skin for a while it makes you
blue so they know who I got hit with it
a little bit and I and I felt that stink
for a very long time some people were
covered in it I just got hit with it a
little bit just covering the protest
there I was there for some of the most
violent most insane interactions where
there was uh you know it's just these
people getting seriously hurt and dying
in on the streets these American and
European antifa are spoiled little brats
yeah go to go to go to Turkey go to
Brazil it was an experience when I was
in Brazil because I've been you know
Luke and I both in pepper sprayed and
tear gas Ad nauseam literally you know
throughout the United States and it's
like you get gas it sucks you cough
whatever you get pepper spray when
you're taking a shower later it burns
when I was in Brazil I was like oh
they're teargassing everybody and then
as soon as the gas hit me like my nose
and eyes just like mucus tears it was
like 10 times more powerful yeah and it
was just like your nose was just
spraying mucus I took my I took my sock
off and jammed it in my mouth to be able
to keep breathing and I was like damn it
was bad yeah in the United States it was
like the lowest tier irritant and it's
just like you know other countries don't
give a damn the reason I brought up
heavy stuff in Israel uh especially uh
in in Gaza they they use like it's a
very serious stuff uh not just CS gas
but uh also uh there's like a skunk
um gun as well they use some Next Level
stuff there which is just crazy it
concerns me that it's being tested on
the on the the rioters or would you call
them protesters but okay so you said
they got black block they were dressing
in Black Block in Hong Kong do you think
that was just were they violent Black
Block violence uh depends on the on on
the circumstances situation there was a
couple instances where uh they stormed a
government building they stormed
Parliament there was also a couple
instances where people were getting
assaulted and beat up but not as much as
of course a lot of the western protests
so there was that as well do you think
they were Justified I don't think so I
think anytime you try to use force and
violence against someone else to enforce
your ideas you're losing and you're in
the wrong American Revolution well
that's a totally different thing that
wasn't a protest right yeah yeah it
started off as a protest in Boston
Harbor but but you have the right new
Defender hold on hold on the American
revolutionary period was 20 years it
wasn't just a protest in Boston Harbor
there's a whole bunch of stuff yeah I
know there was the Boston Massacre
people were being killed soldiers were
barging into people's homes and taking
people's food and sleeping there and
then the the founding fathers wrote
certainly worded letters for years to
the king being like yo please stop yeah
you could argue that the British were
the aggressors and that are and the
British were were stopping U.S vessels
on the sea on uh on the high seas
kidnapping people and forcing them into
servitude of the crown so they were
forced to fight you could argue but were
they justified in their fight
even after that the US is like okay
we're writing this letter to the king
I'm done with this and it's like bro
they've been kidnapping people from
boats and you're writing a letter it was
pretty measured thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time